the return of stargate to our screen
seems to be building real momentum
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are a regular site tracker
you'll know that i have a couple of
people i speak to that working around
amazon and mgm they don't necessarily
work directly for amazon and mgm a
couple of them work for companies that
do work for amazon and mgm
and one of those people have told me
that a vernon sanders who is head of
global television for amazon recently
requested a report that report was
called a social in brackets media
interest report he's requested that
report to cover the period of the 25th
of july to the 31st of july now this i'm
going to tell you more about what the
report is and actually a very
interesting report that was done a few
weeks ago that i've actually got are
some of the data that they got um in
response to
but i'm going to tell you a little bit
more about why this is so interesting
and why the report is being generated
now obviously if you are been watching
the channel you know about these twitter
storm that happened um wednesday last
week around the 25th anniversary of sg1
coming to our screens for the first time
so that twitter storm would be slap bang
in the middle of when this report is
being generated so obviously
this vernon sanders seems to be trying
to gather some information about how
well the twitter storm was received how
much actual traffic it generated and
generally speaking how much interest
there is in within social media for the
stargate project
now the other thing that makes it very
very interesting is that colonel sanders
the other thing that makes it very very
interesting is this vernon sanders is
actually the head of television at
amazon
so jennifer sulk is the head of amazon
studios if it was going to be a movie
project she would be definitely the one
requesting this report but it wasn't it
was vernon sanders head of television
now at the moment there is a lot of
stories to suggest that amazon are
considering more than just a television
series they're actually considering a
movie as well i'm going to talk about
that in my next video because i do have
a little bit of an update on that also
but the fact that this is coming from
vernon sanders head of television to
suggest that maybe the return of a tv
series is currently taking priority by
the way if you are new to the channel
please like subscribe hit the bell
notification really helps us out also if
you enjoy the content please consider
hitting the join button but you can also
go inside as trek.com and look up
merchandise you can pick your team i
picked sg1 but sgu and sga are also
available go and please check it out so
to tell you a little bit more about this
report and what sort of information it
generates
so according to my source
i've run it all down so you'll have to
give me a second here
and the there's a set of algorithms and
they take data points from um things
like viewing figures a metadata on
viewing demographics which i'll tell you
a bit more about a second online
mentions um
tracking
and clicks from related stories articles
they take all of that information and
they run it through a program of
algorithms that then generates
interest points
for um executives to then look at so it
seems to be a lot of percentage points
um i'm sure it's information that they
understand but um i can give you some
reference um when we get into the report
that was actually generated nearly two
months ago for amazon studios so
according to my source again um
depending on the parameters of the
report there can be anything from 50 to
250 individual data point references i
apologize i'm reading my notes because i
don't really understand this so i'm
having to read my notes very carefully
here
the algorithms are designed to score
interest in a subject now apparently
that can be very vague it can be
literally trying to
specifically understand um says interest
in a specific genre say um do people
want to go to the cinema or do they want
to watch movies at home we can then
generate a some sort of interest points
based on that question or it can be
as specific as how popular is a certain
song at the moment and within certain
demographics um how long can we expect
that song to be popular for this sort of
thing around two months ago one of these
reports was requested specifically about
stargate this would have been about
around the time that amazon were
actually also sending out some
questionnaires to certain small number
of amazon
subscribers now my source actually got
to see the report um he says the general
interest for the score over a 12-month
period so it wasn't just a limited time
frame like the current report being
requested by vernon sanders this was a
12-month period that they looked at
the general interest score was between
18 and 25 percent it had obviously lows
and highs within that period according
to the person i speak to anything over
20 is considered statistically
interesting
now again i don't have a frame of
reference for that so it's difficult to
say but to talk to him i basically asked
the question
how excited by those numbers should we
be and he said when it hits highs of 25
that is high particularly for a show
that has been off our screens for over
11 years and the algorithms apparently
do actually take that into an account
when generating this overall percentage
score he was also then able to break it
down in some demographics force as well
he said obviously the strongest
demographic is the 40 to 60 year old
male
in that area i'm a 46 year male myself
um has the strongest interest in
stargate and the strongest interest in
stargate returning
closely followed by a similar age group
in females
one of the things he said that was
really interesting about stargate
compared to other sci-fi series like
star trek that actually the difference
between male and female interest in the
series is very very small in star trek
there is actually quite a large group of
male interest and the female interest is
a little bit lower in stargate it seems
to be similar we said very interesting
and the thing that amazon would be most
interested by is the demographic for 15
to 18 year olds now amazon consider the
15 to 18 year old demographic to be very
very interesting because these are
basically people that watch amazon but
don't have contracts
yet
so they consider these to be
up and coming customers customers that
are going to push and generate further
growth with the amazon prime
subscription channels so if you can get
them on board you're basically hooking
new potential clients he wasn't able to
provide me figures for this but what he
was able to say was that there is shown
to be a steady increase in that
demographic of this 15 to 18 year olds
over stargate over the last 12 months he
put this down to most likely the the um
stargate appearing on pluto um at other
platforms over the last 12 months one of
the things i did ask is that where are
these demographics and where is this
information actually gathered from
now he did say that the united states is
the main source for a lot of this
information but a good chunk also does
come from europe
and he said the united states is where
they have the best demographic
information so
that's basically means that it's when
somebody's actually watching um a tv
show here in the uk
you don't necessarily know who's
watching it could be me it could be my
children it could be my wife
we don't tend to use the individual
accounts that um amazon provide so i
don't if you've got amazon or netflix
you can actually go into and create your
own account and then it remembers what
show you were watching last apparently
here in the europe we don't do that a
great deal but in america they do or at
least a lot more than to make it
statistically relevant so they get much
better information about specifically
who is watching a tv show so from a
demographic point of view the united
states is most interesting but from a
social media point of view he said it
generally doesn't matter the internet is
one big um puddle of information and
it's just drawn from wherever the
information is available so just to
really quickly recap them vernon sanders
head of global television is requesting
information about our twitter store so
get out there and continue it
continue
we want stargate just hashtag stargate
sending your stories telling people on
social media why you love this series
and why we want it back
the storm needs to continue because they
are listening they are actually
requesting reports and getting pretty
little graphs all about our hard work
and our demand they will create a tv
show for us if we shout loud enough
so please please keep it up if you are
new to the channel please like and
subscribe hit that bell notification and
if you enjoy the content please consider
becoming a fully fledged site tracker
hit the join button
[Music]
you